[Music]
Alzheimer's disease Parkinson's
schizophrenia depression it's estimated
that roughly one in three EU citizens
will be affected by a neurological or
psychiatric disease during their
lifetime these statistics are even more
worrying because they will worsen as the
population ages and life expectancy
increases to improve disease management
we need to rethink our health systems
and put more emphasis on scientific
collaboration brain disorder is a global
issue and so of course if we work
together with into 28 member states of
European Union and get a lot of access
to information and data set could help
to get better knowledge and living edge
knowledge is the key for solving the
problem to better grasp the issue we
need to strengthen the links between the
political and the scientific worlds
that's one of the tasks of stoah the
panel for the future of science and
technology of the European Parliament
which organizes meetings between MEP s
and researchers the brain is made up of
more than 100 billion neurons connected
by hundreds of thousands of synapses
understanding how it works is one of
humanity's greatest challenges to help
tackle it the European Union has been
financing the human brain project since
2013
it's a project worth more than 1.9
billion euros that suits to recreate
human brain function by computer
you